لمده 50 عاما تضموا قائمه اليونسكو اماكن
معترفه بهذا في قيمه عالميه استثنائيه
لحمايتها كثير من هذه المواقع تحيط بها
التحديات ونحن جزء منها
انشطهنا من التنميه الى السياحه المفرطه
ولنفهم اكثر
تعالوا معنا الى ايطاليا الى البندقيه
اشهر مواقع التراث العالمي المعرضه للخطر
منذ العام الماضي تحاول اليونسكو عدما
ادراجها الى قائمه التراث المعرض للخطر
والمهدد لكن ذلك يتطلب اجراءات عقدت
لاجلها اجتماعا بالامس لكن اي اجراءات
الناس ستمنع 25 مليون سائح سنويا
وماذا بيد المنظمه لان تفعلها امام
الفيضانات الشديده المتزايده التي فقمها
تغير المناخ
هناك اجراء مهم وهو حظر السفن السياحيه
الكبيره من عبور القنوات المائيه ومن عبور
البحيره وهو ما تم بالفعل بضغط من جماعات
حمايه البيئه لكن الحظره لم يذهب بعيدا
بما يكفي لمعالجه الازمه فهو يخص السفن
التي يزيد وزنها عن 40 الف طن
محاوله اخرى ستبدا مع بدايه العام المقبل
تحول البندقيه الى اول مدينه في العالم
تفرض رسوم دخول اليها وكل الامل هو الطاؤه
وثيره السياحي والزوار
اختفاءه البندقيه التي ادرجت عام
1987 على قائمه التراث العالمي لليونسكو
اختفاء اثار عصر النهضه الايطاليه
البندقيه الواحده من بين ثلاثه وخمسين
موقعا معرضا للخطر ومهددا